The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So once you
have the batteries out,
they go in the
back of the camera.
This spot here, if you notice
a little notch is there,
just make notches on the
battery, on the bottom of it,
match up with the notches here.
And then just slide
it into place.
There should be a push
button on the larger battery.
Make sure that's on the bottom.
If that's on the
bottom, it will match up
with the notches on the back.
And it should just
snap into place.
I think it goes in
the other way, yep.
And you just got to
kind of feel it out.
There you go, until it stops.
There you go.
You guys are
already on the tape.
All right, once you
have the battery in,
there's this little
wheel right here.
If you could just push
the green button in on it
and slide it to on.
And once that happens, you
should be in tape mode.
The green light should be at the
very top of the three choices.
Excellent.
All right, now, you guys should
all have cassettes, tapes.
To open the cassette, or
where you put the cassette in,
you just see this little
thing on the bottom, where
it says open eject,
just slide it forward
and pull the cover open.
And it will pop
out automatically.
And then you just have
to put the cassette in.
Make sure that the cassette
is face up when you put it in.
AUDIENCE: Like this?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Just like-- oh no, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so
like it was before?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And then if you
just push that down, it should
go back in automatically.
Cool.
And then you can close the--
and if you push that down,
it will go in automatically.
And then you can
just close this.
Everybody there?
Sweet.
Now, on the actual lens hood,
some of them might be mixed up.
But it's either on your
left or your right side.
There's a little switch.
It says close and open.
If you could just
push that to open,
just so you can see stuff when
you turn the camera on or look
through the viewfinder,
or the LCD screen.
Now, there are two
ways of doing this.
Right now, I'm just going to
run you through the LCD screens.
So it's right here on the
left hand side of the camera.
If you can just open that up.
You can also close this,
look through the viewfinder.
There's something right
underneath the viewfinder
called the diopter.
So if you see a
blurry image, you
can just push that to the side.
Try to sharpen it.
Sometimes with the LCD screens,
focus is hard to gauge.
So the viewfinder
sometimes is a better gauge
of whether or not
things are in focus.
So underneath the
viewfinder, again, there's
this little switch.
If it looks blurry, just
play with the switch
until it becomes clearer.
Again, if you guys
look at the LCD panel
when you open it up,
on the bottom right,
there's a little button
called the P menu,
which stands for personal menu.
The menu on this, the regular
menu, is pretty extensive.
And there are a lot
of things in there
that you don't really need or
that you'll never really use.
So if you just hit
the P Menu now,
you'll have two pages open up
that you can scroll through.
And what I've done is
I consolidated the menu
into the most relevant choices
that you guys will probably
run into when you're
out there shooting.
The top left is
the regular menu.
So if you ever want to get
more like advanced and in depth
into what the camera
can do, the top
left, just go through
the menu choices there.
Right now it's pretty cursory as
far as what we're going to do.
So as you can see, you have
the audio channel one level,
audio channel two
level, those buttons.
A lot of people, they
make the mistake of they
try to record audio,
they'll go to the volume,
which is really controlling
just the headphone volume.
So sometimes people come back
be like, the levels are too low.
And it's like, you
have to go through.
Inside the camera case, there's
a little [INAUDIBLE] adaptor,
which allows you to hook up
better shotgun microphones,
so you get better sound.
So those are the two
audio level channels
that you're going to be
using or playing with,
instead of just the volume.
That's why they're up there.
The zebra, which is right
there next to audio channel two
level, the zebra is helpful.
I think you can set it
at either a 70 or 100.
And basically it tells you
when something is overexposed,
you'll see little zebra
stripes on the screen.
So say you're playing
with exposure.
And you're worried about
whether or not like you've
hit the ceiling of what the
camera can actually record.
Basically, you want
to explain IREs
or is it too much in depth?
PROFESSOR 2: Well,
yeah, remember
I talked about exposure
and the aperture.
In video, the exposure is
measured in units called
IRE units, which stands for--
PROFESSOR: International
Radio Engineers.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah,
it's basically
a standard that was
created 50 years ago
that measures the brightness
or the exposure of an image.
And if you go past
100 IRE units,
you're not going
to record anything.
That's basically where
you hit pure white.
And adding light just
gives you more white.
PROFESSOR: It's just blown out.
So if you go into the editing
room and you try to bring some
detail back into
that, you can't.
Because there's nothing there.
PROFESSOR 2: So
the zebra stripes
tell you when you are either
approaching or exceeding
that threshold.
PROFESSOR: And if you guys
want to just hit the zebra
button right now, because
it's one of those things
that you probably use, just
hit zebra on the touch screen.
And if you notice,
there's three options.
There's off, 70, and 100.
What I would recommend is
when you use the zebra,
I would set it to 100.
Because that's the
absolute threshold.
I mean, that's the
highest you can go.
When you see zebras
on 100, then you
may want to lower your exposure.
And if you hit
that little button
on the bottom right of the
screen, the turn around button,
we'll get back to
the personal menu.
Now, after zebra, there is
the white balance option.
White balance is
one of those things
that you want to
make sure you do,
but after you set your
exposure, after you've framed up
your image, after you focused.
But it is important to do.
It's all about the
color temperature.
And if you don't white
balance correctly,
your image could look too--
like have this really ugly tint
of blue, or tint of orange,
or something.
You want to make
sure that the color
temperature is represented
correctly within your camera.
And if you guys look at the
right side of the camera,
toward the front, you'll
see a little round button
called the Assign button.
What I've done with
all these cameras
is I've already programmed
one push white balance
to the Assign button.
So instead of having
to go through the menu
options, whenever you
want to white balance,
you can just press
the Assign button.
And it will white
balance for you.
So it's just a little
shortcut that all the cameras
should be able to access.
When you are white balancing,
whenever you're going out
on a shoot, try to make sure
you have a white piece of paper.
That's probably the
simplest way to do it.
If you're working with
somebody, just to have them
stand in front of the camera.
Zoom so you you're filling the
frame with about at least 80%
of the white paper.
Press the Assign button.
There should be a blinking--
should be a blinking symbol.
And once it stops blinking,
you're properly white balanced.
PROFESSOR 2: So just to give
you a little more background
on that.
Basically what you're doing when
you hold up that piece of paper
is you're saying to the camera,
OK, camera, this is white.
Make this white.
And whatever the kind
of color of light
you have shining on that
paper affects how the paper is
going to read to the camera.
These fluorescent lights
look very, very different
compared to the
daylight outside.
You can actually
see it in your eye.
Our eyes are great at adjusting.
But if you stare at
the light and then you
look down at the
exterior, you can
see that it's a little blue.
So you put the paper under
whatever light you're filming.
You frame it up.
And you push that
button, which is saying,
OK, make that image white.
Balance all the
colors in the sensor,
so that comes out white.
And then all the
other colors will be
relatively true and accurate.
PROFESSOR: Because white
contains all the other colors.
It's a conglomeration
of all the other colors.
Like if you can represent
white accurately,
then all the other colors will
be represented accurately as
well.
Right next to white
balance is spot focus,
which is kind of nifty.
Basically, if you hit
Spot Focus, just press it,
you'll open up
this little screen.
And if you press something
on the touch screen,
it will focus that
object or that person.
So you may want to like--
if you guys notice on the back
of the camera, on the right,
there is a little lever, which
allows you to zoom in and out.
Everybody-- what you may want
to do is just zoom in, go
a little--
not too much telephoto.
Zoom into something
and try the spot focus
and see how it works.
See how it adjusts after a
few seconds so it's in focus?
So if you just press something
with the spot focus enabled,
press something on the screen.
And after a few seconds,
it should drift into focus.
Is it working?
It's working for me.
The best way to judge is if
you zoom into something, so
go telephoto for something.
Yeah, if you just wait a few
seconds, it should kick in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
If you see the zebra, that
means that that's overexposed.
It's not a huge deal
here, because I mean,
it's not a detail shot.
If it's something that you--
if you want to keep the
detail in something,
like whether it's a person or
an object, if you see the zebra,
you may want to bring
the exposure down, just
so you can keep that detail.
And it will record
it accurately.
But for something like
the edge of a table,
it's not a big deal.
Because there's no
real detail in it.
If you guys go back
to the P menu--
and I'll try to speed this up.
PROFESSOR 2: We're doing great.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
Back to the P menu, if you
scroll down to the second page,
you'll see peaking, histogram,
study shot, exposure lever,
and spot meter.
Is everybody with me?
Sometimes with the
LCD screens, it's
really hard to gauge focus.
So there's something called
the peaking function,
which is the top left
of the second screen.
If you guys want
to just hit that,
you'll see there's four options.
There's off, white,
red, and yellow.
And what peaking does--
and by the way, you can't
have peaking and zebra
at the same time.
They can't both be
enabled at the same time.
So what you probably
want to do is
if you're going to be in the
same area, set your exposure
first with the zebra.
Make sure that
nothing's overexposed.
And if you want to use the
peaking, go to that after.
But with these LCD screens,
where it's really hard
to gauge focus,
you have the option
of surrounding people
or objects that
are in focus with
the color white,
like a white outline, a red
outline, or a yellow outline.
So anything that's
in focus, you can
choose one of those options.
And the person or
thing in focus will
have a slight trace of white,
red, or yellow around them.
And again, with these
screens, whether or not
sometimes they're smudged
or the resolution just
isn't very good,
sometimes that's
a good option to have available.
Because, like Chris was saying,
if something's out of focus
and you bring it
into the editing room
and it's blown up even
bigger, you can really
tell that something's soft.
So peaking is one
of those things
that you may want to pull
out from time to time,
just to make sure
that you're in focus.
PROFESSOR 2: And one
other note about focus.
Sometimes you'll
find, and today is
one of those days, when it's
really, really bright out,
the screen may not
be your best option
in terms of seeing the image.
If you close the
screen, you can actually
look through the viewfinder.
And then your eye is shadowed.
So even in very, very
bright conditions,
you can see pretty accurately
what image you're getting.
And that can be very helpful,
especially for focus.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Unfortunately,
you cannot use the viewfinder
and the screen at the same time.
PROFESSOR: No, you can't.
After peeking, there's
the histogram, which
measures your exposure levels.
I think to the left of the
screen is your black levels.
And to the right
is your highlights.
So if you really want to have
a nice balance in contrast
to your frame, the histogram
is a good thing to have open.
It doesn't take up too much
space on the LCD screen.
But we can talk about
that more later on.
Steady shot, whenever
you're not using a tripod,
make sure that steady
shot is enabled.
Because it over
compensates, like
if your camera's
going one way, if it's
a little shaky with
your hand held work,
steady shot just
over compensates
with the movement of the frame.
So it just stays steadier than
if you didn't have it enabled.
Exposure lever, it's
not really a big deal.
Spot meter, a spot meter
is kind of like the--
was it the focus, Peter?
PROFESSOR 2: Spot meter is--
PROFESSOR: No, but
what was the other one?
AUDIENCE: Spot focus?
PROFESSOR: Spot focus, yes.
It's like spot focus, except
it works with exposure.
So if you guys want
to hit spot meter,
this is good for like
interviews or anything
with people, especially if
say there's somebody sitting
right in front of
a window and you're
getting all kinds of
zebras in the window,
because it's overexposed.
But you want to make
sure the person sitting
in front of the window
is properly exposed.
If you, again, just like spot
focus, if you hit that person,
or whatever it is
want to make sure
is properly exposed
on the screen,
it will adjust your
exposure automatically.
So it tries to maintain proper
exposure on whatever you
touch on the screen.
And that's good in a
jam if you ever need it.
As far as the basic
functions that
are on the outside of the
camera, that are on the shell,
there are two, well
actually, three ways
to zoom, to go from
wide to telephoto.
One is the ring.
But what I would
recommend everybody
do is you see on the left
hand side of the camera
at the front, right
behind the ring?
AUDIENCE: Show me.
PROFESSOR: Here.
Right above where it says
focus, there are three options.
You can go all the way
to the front for zoom.
You can bring it toward
the middle for auto focus.
Or if you switch it all
the way to the back,
you can have manual focus.
AUDIENCE: Hold still, please.
Show me on top.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 2: Are you zooming in?
PROFESSOR: Think it might
be in the light, all right.
So if you go all the
way back, I would
recommend keeping that
on manual focus, which
is all the way toward the back.
Because you only have one ring.
And you want to make sure that
that's freed up for focus.
Because there are
already two ways to zoom.
On the LCD screen itself, on the
left hand side of the screen,
you'll see that
there's a W and a T.
So if you want to zoom
out, you'd hit the W.
And it's kind of slow.
If you want to zoom in, you
hit the T for telephoto.
If that's too slow
for you, there's
also a snap zoom on the back
right of the camera, which
is this lever right here.
AUDIENCE: Can you say
that one more time for me?
PROFESSOR: Which part?
AUDIENCE: What is the snap zoom?
PROFESSOR: The snap zoom is on
the back right of the camera.
And if the zoom on the LCD goes
a little too slowly for you,
I would recommend the snap zoom,
which is pressure sensitive.
So it doesn't mean that you
can't control your zoom.
It just means if you want
the option of going faster,
you have it.
So if you guys
want to play around
with the zoom on the back
right, again, it's labeled,
so W and T. So W for
wide, T for telephoto.
So just play around
with that for a second.
I'm zooming right now.
AUDIENCE: I'm just going to
let that out of your shirt.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So the top left,
now that it's set
on manual focus,
that switch, you
can now focus with
the focus ring.
So again, the best way to play
around with focus is use either
the zoom tools on the LCD or
on the back of the camera,
and maybe zoom in to one of the
chairs or something that's--
one of the cases or zoom
in fairly closely, and just
play with the focus ring.
So you get a good
sense of how it works.
I'm going to focus on
your headphones, Brian.
I'm going to focus those there.
Excellent.
All right, last
thing is exposure.
If you guys look
toward the front
of the camera, on the bottom,
on the left, there's a lever.
You move that up and
down to control exposure.
So again, that's the F
stop or the aperture.
So to make the image
brighter or darker,
I want you guys play
around with that.
Tell me if it's working.
If it's not working,
there's an easy fix.
AUDIENCE: Can you just
turn the camera towards me
so I can that?
Point to it again.
PROFESSOR: This is
the exposure lever.
Is that working for everybody?
Because sometimes you have to
press the button next to it.
It's kind of quirky.
There should also be a bar
on the bottom of the screen,
as your exposing.
Is everybody comfortable
with the basic functions
of the camera?
PROFESSOR 2: And
obviously, you're
going to gain a
lot of experience
very quickly with how
these things work.
So if you're a little
bit, you know, obviously
at C with some of them,
don't worry too much.
AUDIENCE: How do you
turn the volume down,
so it's not beeping
all the time?
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's easy.
It's in the-- oh,
do you want to?
PROFESSOR 2: No, go ahead.
PROFESSOR: It's in the menu.
So that's one of those that--
let me turn mine
back on actually--
that's in the main menu.
So if you hit the P menu, and
on the top left, the menu.
I believe it's in camera set.
So if camera set is already
highlighted, press OK.
And scroll down.
And you should see
beep eventually.
I can hear that beeping.
Oh, actually it's
in the toolbox.
AUDIENCE: Toolbox?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're going
to have to scroll down a while.
Keep going.
AUDIENCE: Volume?
PROFESSOR: No.
That's for the headphones.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And beep is close.
BP is-- there it is.
AUDIENCE: All right.
PROFESSOR 2: So you can see
that these menus are very
complicated, the main menu.
AUDIENCE: There we go.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: No problem.
Anything else?
Questions?
Solutions?
No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So if you have somebody
else with you--
I mean, you could
probably do it yourself--
hold a white sheet of paper in
front of your camera and make
sure that your frame is--
PROFESSOR 2: Here,
I'll be your model.
So again, what I
would do is make sure
that the light that is
hitting your subject,
if the subject is
me, is also hitting
the paper, which it is now.
AUDIENCE: So should I
zoom into the white paper?
PROFESSOR 2: Zoom
into the paper, yeah.
PROFESSOR: And make sure
it fills at least 80%
of the frame.
AUDIENCE: So every
time you change your--
PROFESSOR: Your lighting.
AUDIENCE: Oh, just your--
PROFESSOR 2: Just
the lighting, yeah.
This would be a difficult
room, because the light
by the windows is very different
from the light over here.
So you might adjust--
PROFESSOR: If you press
the assign button,
you'll see a little blinking--
it looks like a flower almost.
PROFESSOR 2: If the
blinds were closed
and it was all
fluorescence, once you
adjusted for these
lights, you would be fine.
PROFESSOR: There it is.
Once that stops blinking, you'll
be properly light balanced.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah, exactly.
And once you go outside today to
shoot, once you adjust it once,
you'll be OK.
Then you'd have to
probably adjust it again,
as long as you stay outside.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait,
it's blinking slower.
It was blinking faster.
Then it was blinking slower.
PROFESSOR: Let me see.
It should stop blinking.
PROFESSOR 2: It's not working?
PROFESSOR: It's still blinking.
PROFESSOR 2: Uh-oh.
PROFESSOR: All right.
All right, it should be OK.
It shouldn't be blinking.
But the color temperature
looked to change,
so it seemed to change.
All right, now, one more quick
thing before we head out.
PROFESSOR 2: Do you want
to talk about the tripod?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
what we're going to do.
So now everybody has tape
in the camera, right?
Because once we put the plates
on the bottom of the cameras,
it's going to be impossible to
take any tape out or put it in.
Everybody has tape in?
PROFESSOR 2: One
disadvantage with this design
is that if you are
shooting with a tripod,
you have to take it off the
tripod in order to change tape.
That's how they
compromised and made
a nice camera that's so small.
But anyway, these tripods
are about twice the weight
of the camera and
very cumbersome.
So I know you'll
want to not use them.
And in some
situations, that's OK.
But I also think it's very
important to know about them
and get used to using them.
Because for a lot of
situations, interviews,
elegant architectural
shots, beauty shots,
it is important to use them
and to know how to use them.
PROFESSOR: Anything that
involves control, as
much control as possible.
PROFESSOR 2: Exactly, if you're
not shooting something that's
a lot of action or motion.
PROFESSOR: Right.
PROFESSOR 2: So
anyway, go ahead, Dave.
PROFESSOR: So if
you guys could just
grab the tripod bags that are
right there against the wall.
There is a plate on top.
And you want to release it
from the head of the tripod.
So there's a little lever
on the right hand side.
Or there's a little latch.
And you just want
to turn that latch.
And then on the left hand
side, there is a yellow button
that you want to press in.
And then your plate should
slide right off the top.
PROFESSOR 2: If you push that--
make sure that that's loose.
Yeah, it's this way.
So that goes on the
bottom of the camera.
PROFESSOR: Once
that's off, you'll
notice that there's two holes
on the bottom of the camera.
Make sure that, if you
turn the plate over,
you'll see there's a word
lens and there's an arrow.
Just make sure that
arrow is pointing
toward the front of the camera.
And then tighten up the screw.
I wish-- yes, the
best thing to use
is like the flat side
of a key or a quarter,
and make sure that
screw is really tight.
Because that's basically if
you're tilting and panning,
that's what's keeping
your camera on the tripod.
And you don't want
it falling off.
PROFESSOR 2: So the whole
purpose of this plate
is basically so
that you can quickly
release the camera
from the tripod
and quickly put it
back on, in case
you want to go handheld
in the middle of a shoot,
and then easily slide
it back onto the tripod.
And just one thing to note.
It's almost the
number one thing that
happens when equipment
gets checked in and out
is that people forget
to take the plate
off the bottom of the camera.
The plate stays with the
tripod, not with the camera.
So you always have to remember
to unattach it and slide it
back onto the tripod when
you return the equipment.
PROFESSOR: Now, if
you have the plate
on the bottom of
the camera and it's
the screw is really
tight on the bottom,
make sure it's really tight.
Again, the flat head
of a key or a quarter
would work very, very well.
And it looks like
you're all set.
If you just from the
back slide it back
into the top of the
tripod head and then
tighten that screw on the
right again, or the latch.
Make sure it's really
tight, so the camera, again,
doesn't slide off.
PROFESSOR 2: No, actually,
I guess it's all right.
I tend to line that one up.
See that little brass--
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Now,
on the left side,
there should be
a handle that you
can turn to adjust the fluidity
of the actual tripod head.
So if you want to have a
little more resistance,
you can play with
that if you want.
A little less
resistance, play with it.
PROFESSOR 2: You slide
it on from-- yeah.
So again, you push that
in and slide it on.
Let go of that.
Make sure that it's just
engaged exactly like that.
Now let go of the red one.
And now lock it with that.
see?
So now it's nice and snug.
And then if you want
to take it off quickly,
you always hold on to it, so
it doesn't go anywhere, right?
You just undo that one.
Push that button.
It goes on back to front.
So it comes off that
way, goes on that way.
This is just like
an emergency thing.
So let's say this was blue--
PROFESSOR: But whenever
it's like unattended,
make sure that this is
all the way forward,
yeah, so it doesn't go anywhere.
But this is how much fluidity.
Also, right here, you can
adjust the fluidity too.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
PROFESSOR 2: This is
really like a basic thing.
Like the camera
could easily fall.
PROFESSOR: And I guess the last
thing would be just balancing
it.
PROFESSOR 2: I mean,
they're so light that it--
but yeah, you're right,
so that it doesn't
tilt forward or backward.
PROFESSOR: No, I'm talking about
making sure that it's balanced,
like the level.
PROFESSOR 2: Oh, level, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So there's a
little knob on the underneath.
If you turn that, you can loosen
the actual head from the legs.
And yeah, just make
sure it's level there.
And then tighten it.
And whenever--
AUDIENCE: Oh, should
I be holding this?
PROFESSOR 2: But anyway, so
this is just really up to you.
PROFESSOR: And just make
sure it's really tight.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Can I just hold this?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's probably best
to hold the camera
when are you doing it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: One thing
you could try to do
is just nudge it with like
a closed fist or something.
AUDIENCE: Is that good?
PROFESSOR 2: That's the tilt.
AUDIENCE: Tilt?
Which one's [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 2: It's this.
It's just how much
you tighten it.
So like you can tighten it.
You don't want to tighten
it so much that you would
break the tripod obviously.
But like this is loose.
This is tighter.
Then I think-- here, I think
this is the pan friction.
So you can add friction
by turning that as well.
So you can both tilt and pan
at different rates of drag.
And you can mimic, as I said,
mimic a much heavier camera,
like that camera.
OK, questions?
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What's the lever
near the light [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: That is
for the head itself.
I think that's if you're going
to be like taking it apart.
AUDIENCE: Which
way should it be?
PROFESSOR: It should
be pushed forward.
PROFESSOR 2: OK, if everyone is
kind of at a comfortable place,
we'll take a short break.
I mean, you're welcome to stay
here and keep playing around
with the camera.
Or you can just relax.
We'll come back in
five or 10 minutes.
And I'll talk a little bit about
the assignment, the exercise.
And then the rest of
the time we'll basically
go out and do a little filming.
I have eight separate
kinds of subjects,
types of subjects, that I want
you to try to go and film.
And if you only film six
of them, that's fine.
This is not necessarily
a graded exercise.
But these are the
kinds of things
that I think would be great
for you to experience doing.
So film a landscape or
an architectural view
of an exterior of a building.
So in other words, an
environmental shot.
Film an interior space, either
static or moving, panning,
going through the space,
revealing the space.
You can go to Stata.
You can go to the hall.
You can just be creative.
Explore an environment
with a shot.
Film a portrait of a person.
And we're not doing audio now.
We're not doing sound.
We're not doing interviews.
We're not worrying
about that yet.
Create a nice portrait
of a person visually.
Follow something.
And that could be handheld.
It could be a pan.
It could be both.
Just move the camera and
figure out a motivation
for moving the camera.
Remember what we talked
about that when you're
moving the camera, you should be
doing something with that move.
You can either literally follow
a person or some other moving
object.
You can reveal something.
So move the camera.
Film a close up of something.
In other words, you know how
Brian, our camera person,
was zooming in on Dave
as he showed the buttons?
Film an activity and
illustrate something
with the camera, probably
in a close up like that.
But if you find some
other way to do it
or some other shot that
tells that kind of story,
that's fine too.
Think about a way to employ
a foreground in a background
element.
So a person in the
foreground, something
in the background, two people,
whatever you might want to do.
And reveal something
with the camera.
That could be the same as
the move the camera exercise.
Again, if you're actually come
back with eight shots here.
Reveal something
with the camera.
And then the last
thing, film something
that you think is
a beautiful image.
Create something that is at
least your attempt at making
something that's beautiful.
Could be a person.
Could be an image.
Could be a landscape.
Could be a close up.
Could be one of
these other things.
But try to create something
aesthetically pleasing.
PROFESSOR: And whatever
you're panning,
it's good to position
your body where
you'll be for the last frame.
So if I'm walking
that way, you probably
want to position
your body like here.
Because that way,
you're unwinding
rather than like
you're constantly
stumbling with your feet.
So find out what
your last frame is.
And try to position
yourself there.
Because you're going to be
uncoiling your body rather
than moving your feet.
But we'll try it a few times.
Do you want try it once
without recording it
and just see how it goes?
You can practice just tracking.
AUDIENCE: So am I supposed
to shoot [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: No, so I'm
going to stand there.
So [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, do we have
to use the spot focus?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean, the
thing with the spot focus
is it takes a few
seconds just to adjust.
So you may want to try
to just manually focus.
Or you may want to just try to
focus as I get closer and then
worry about focus then.
But also, when you're
panning, when I get closer,
you could probably
tilt a little bit just
to try to keep like the same
composition, like medium shot.
Try to go with a medium shot.
It's going to be difficult.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's a medium shot?
PROFESSOR: So like from here up.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: My question
is because you're
going to have different-- if
you do the spot focus, then it's
going to focus on you,
automatically focus on you,
as you're walking?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean, I think
it may take a couple of seconds
to readjust with motion.
So it might be, yeah, just
for like a few seconds.
But you can try that.
It would kind of cool.
Give it a shot.
And you may want to just adjust
the drag on this a little bit.
Because right now,
it's pretty tight.
Just give me the OK sign.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I forgot to zoom in after--
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I was
trying to [INAUDIBLE]..
I was so worried
about the frame,
I forgot to actually zoom in.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I mean, what you could do
is try to worry about one
thing at a time, like
worry about the framing.
Maybe try to keep
me in a medium shot.
And then stuff like
focus, that'll take time
to juggle all things at once.
So maybe just worry
about tracking my motion
and keeping me in a medium
shot from the waist up.
You didn't get the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you're going
to have to adjust
the focal length at some point,
just to keep me a medium shot.
So let's try that.
AUDIENCE: By adjusting
focal length, you mean?
PROFESSOR: Zooming in and out.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: You're possibly
going to have to zoom out
a little bit when I get closer.
AUDIENCE: Panning and zooming.
PROFESSOR: And a little
bit of a tilt too, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Do you guys want
to try some of the other shots
on the list?
AUDIENCE: Can I
try one more time?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: My first
attempt was a disaster.
PROFESSOR: Do want
the same thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just the same.
PROFESSOR: OK, just give me
the OK sign when you're ready.
And when you're
focusing on a person,
try to zoom in all the way
and look for like features
on the person's face that
are really distinctive.
Those are the best
places to focus.
But I mean, you're going to
be out of focus at some point
anyway.
AUDIENCE: OK, you can go ahead.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, I mean, this
is a great place to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I was over across the street.
And that's just a
hallway that we were in.
So this is definitely
a lot more pleasing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What I find
difficult is I see something--
PROFESSOR: Just make sure
you're balanced, level.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I keep
seeing pictures.
But then when I film it, I
feel like it's not really
a video someone would
be interested in.
You know?
PROFESSOR: Well, these are
just exercises at this point.
AUDIENCE: This one--
isn't this [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Just fill the
frame with something white.
AUDIENCE: Maybe zoom into
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
PROFESSOR: And make sure
that whatever you're
filming the frame
with is going to be
in your main light source,
under your main light source.
Actually, you got plenty
of light to choose from.
AUDIENCE: It's mostly white.
PROFESSOR: Just remember
what he was saying
about asymmetry in a frame.
It would be really interesting
if it's asymmetrical rather
than symmetrical.
AUDIENCE: How can we
make this asymmetrical?
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking about that.
PROFESSOR: You might want
to work on exposure too.
You see, you have
the histogram up.
All those levels right there,
that's all your black level.
You have hardly anything
in the highlights.
The right of it
would be highlights.
So if you want a
nice contrast, try
to balance it out a little bit.
So it's spread out
in a histogram.
AUDIENCE: Like that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
When you're panning,
try to figure out
where your end shot will be.
And stay in that shot.
So [INAUDIBLE].
So instead of
shuffling your feet,
you're just unwinding your body
into its natural place of rest.
You know what I mean?
So you're unwinding your
body rather than doing this.
And then it's like all
jittery, staggered.
So try to figure out what
your last frame will be.
And then you might want to
adjust the handle, whatever's
more comfortable.
But just unwind your
body rather than
like shuffle with your feet.
And you'll get a
much smoother pan.
AUDIENCE: We did
exterior, interior.
Portrait of a person
we haven't really done.
What is that?
Like just zooming it
at someone's face?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's just
finding a person, placing
them interestingly in a frame.
I would do like a medium
shot from waist up.
Play around with like
focal length for that.
You could do a wide
shot, medium, and a close
up of the same person.
But again, with that, just
remember negative space.
If you have the person
looking at something,
just make sure that whatever
they're looking for, or looking
at, the negative space is in
front of their line of sight.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
look like they're looking--
PROFESSOR: Looking off
frame, exactly, yeah.
How the screen's
divided into thirds.
Try to keep the eyes somewhere
in that top third, that
cross line.
AUDIENCE: OK.